let's get that police update from Sussex
Police Headquarters detective
superintendent from the Metropolitan
Police I'm James Collis I'm the chief
superintendent here in Sussex police we
intend to read out some short statements
and we won't be taking questions at the
end
it is my very sad duty to update this
afternoon
police officers searching a wooded area
close to where Constance and Mark Gordon
were arrested discovered the remains of
a baby
a post-mortem examination will be held
in due course
a crime scene is in place and work at
the location is expected to continue for
some time
this is an outcome that myself and that
many officers who have been part of this
search had hoped would not happen
I recognize the impact this news will
have on the many people who have been
following the story closely
and can assure them that we will do
everything we possibly can to establish
what has happened
Constance Martin
and Mark Gordon remain in custody after
the application for the extension of
their detention for a further 36 hours
was sought and granted by Brighton
magistrates Court
it's an imperative now that the media
and members of the public refrain from
speculation and comments online that
could be prejudicial to the potential
Court proceedings
no further information about the
discovery will be shared at this time
I ask again that anyone with information
that could support the investigation
should call the instant room on 0208 345
-3854
I'd just like to thank the media the
public and our policing colleagues in
Sussex for their continued support
I would first and foremost like to
extend my heartfelt condolences on
behalf of Sussex police to The Wider
family of the baby at this time
I understand that the conclusion of this
search will be heartbreaking for the
local community and The Wider public
who have been impacted by and so
supportive of this search and the
investigation from the outset
I would like to thank again the public
including the member of public whose
information led to the arrests
the huge number of people who came
forward with information
and those that have volunteered to
assist with the searches
we continue to support the Metropolitan
Police as they conduct their
investigation and also the wider
Community as we all come to terms with
this tragedy thank you very much
everyone
thank you very much